nous sommes irrémédiablement égoïstes,
c'est de la science de salon.
Il n'y a pas une seule étude sociologique
ou psychologique, démontrant cela.
En fait, c'est le contraire.
Mon ami, Daniel Batson a passé toute sa vie
à étudier et observer les gens dans des situations complexes.
Et bien sûr, nous sommes parfois égoïstes, certains plus que d'autres.
Mais il a constaté que systématiquement,
il y a un nombre important de personnes
qui se comportent de manière altruiste.
Devant une personne blessée ou souffrante,
vous l'aidez, par empathie.
Vous ne supportez pas la souffrance et donc vous l'aidez.
Il a testé cela et en a conclu qu'on peut clairement être altruistes.
C'est une bonne nouvelle.
Nous pouvons aussi observer la banalité de la gentillesse.
Regardez ici.
En sortant, nous n'allons pas dire : « C'est vraiment bien.
Il n'y a eu aucune bagarre pendant cette conférence sur l'altruisme. »
C'est attendu, non ?
S'il y avait eu une bagarre, nous en parlerions pendant des mois.
La banalité de la gentillesse n'attire pas notre attention,
mais elle existe.
Maintenant, regardez ceci.
Certains psychologues, quand je leur dis
que je dirige 140 projets humanitaires
dans l'Himalaya qui me rendent heureux,
disent : « Oh, donc vous le faites pour vous sentir bien.
Ce n'est pas altruiste. Vous le faites pour vous-même. »
Pensez-vous que cet homme, en se jetant devant le train,
se disait : « Je vais me sentir si bien après ? »
(Rires)
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Ils disent : « Quand on lui a demandé, il a dit
qu'il n'avait pas le choix, qu'il devait sauter ! »
S'il n'a pas le choix, c'est automatique. Ce n'est ni égoïste, ni altruiste.
Pas le choix ?
Cet homme ne va pas réfléchir pendant une demi-heure,
« J'aide ou je n'aide pas ? »
Il agit. Il a le choix, mais il est évident et immédiat.
Et lui aussi, il avait le choix.
(Rires)
Certaines personnes ont le choix, comme le pasteur André Trocmé et sa femme,
et tout le village de Chambon-sur-Lignon en France.
Pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale, ils ont sauvé 3 500 juifs,
leur offrant un abri, les amenant en Suisse,
malgré le danger, malgré le risque pour eux et leurs proches.
Alors, oui, l'altruisme existe.
Mais, c'est quoi l'altruisme ?
C'est vouloir que les autres soient heureux et trouvent le bonheur.
L'empathie, c'est la résonance affective ou cognitive qui nous permet
de discerner que telle personne est joyeuse, telle triste.
Mais l'empathie seule ne suffit pas.
Une personne souvent confrontée à la souffrance
va se retrouver en détresse, en état de burn-out.
Elle aura davantage besoin d'amour bienveillant.
Avec Tania Singer de l'Institut Max Planck de Leipzig,
on a démontré que les réseaux cérébraux de l'empathie et la bonté sont différents.
Et tout cela est bien fait,
nous en héritons via l'évolution, les soins maternels et l'amour parental
mais nous devons élargir ceci.
Par exemple, l'élargir à l'égard d'autres espèces.
Pour une société plus altruiste, il nous faut deux choses :
un changement individuel et un changement sociétal.
Mais, le changement individuel est-il possible ?
2000 ans d'études contemplatives nous dit que oui, il l'est.
Et, 15 années de collaboration avec les neurosciences et l'épigénétique
montrent que nos cerveaux changent en les entraînant à l'altruisme.
J'ai donc passé 120 heures dans une machine IRM.
Me voici après ma première séance de deux heures et demie.
Le résultat a été publié dans de nombreux articles scientifiques.
Il montre sans ambiguïté un changement structurel
et fonctionnel du cerveau lorsque vous l'entraînez à l'amour altruiste.
Juste pour vous donner une idée :
à gauche, le cerveau d'un méditant au repos,
pendant la méditation, observez toute l'activité,
et le groupe de contrôle au repos, aucune activité,
en méditant, aucune activité non plus.
Ils n'ont pas été formés.
Faut-il 50 000 heures de méditation pour y arriver ? Non.
20 minutes par jour de méditation sérieuse pendant 4 semaines suffisent
pour observer une différence avec le cerveau du groupe de contrôle.
C'est seulement 20 minutes par jour pendant quatre semaines.
Même chez les jeunes enfants – comme l'a démontré Richard Davidson.
8 semaines de gratitude, de bonté, de coopération, de respiration consciente.
Ce ne sont que des enfants, vous vous dites.
Mais voyez, après 8 semaines,
la courbe du comportement prosocial, la ligne bleue.
Puis vient le test scientifique ultime : le test des autocollants.
Vous demandez à l'enfant d'indiquer son meilleur ami,
l'enfant qu'il aime le moins, un enfant inconnu et un enfant malade,
puis ils doivent leur donner des autocollants.
Avant le programme, ils les donnent presque tous à leur meilleur ami.
Après 20 minutes de méditation, 3 fois par semaine, pendant 8 semaines,
ces enfants de quatre, cinq ans ne discriminent plus personne :
ils donnent le même nombre d'autocollants à tout le monde.
Voilà quelque chose que toutes les écoles du monde devraient faire.
Que pouvons-nous faire maintenant ?
(Applaudissements)
Lorsque le Dalaï-lama l'a appris, il a dit à Davidson :
« Va dans 10 écoles, puis 100, puis l'ONU et le monde entier. »
Alors, que faire maintenant ?
Le changement individuel est possible.
Devons-nous attendre l'apparition d'un gène de l'altruisme chez l'Homme ?
Cela prendra 50 000 ans, beaucoup trop pour l'environnement.
Heureusement, nous pouvons compter sur l'évolution de la culture.
Les experts l'ont démontré : la culture change plus vite que les gènes.
Voilà une bonne nouvelle.
Observez à quel point les opinions face à la guerre ont changé.
Les changements culturels et individuels se façonnent mutuellement.
Oui, nous pouvons créer une société plus altruiste.
Mais comment faire ?
Pour ma part, je vais repartir en Orient.
Nous traitons 100 000 patients par an grâce à nos projets.
Nous envoyons 25 000 enfants à l'école, et nous augmenterons ce chiffre de 4 %.
Certains disent : « Ça marche en pratique tout ça,
mais est-ce que ça marche en théorie ? »
C'est ce qu'on appelle de la déviance positive.
Je vais retourner dans mon ermitage
afin de trouver en moi le moyen de mieux servir les autres.
Mais au niveau mondial, que pouvons-nous faire ?
Il nous faut faire trois choses.
Améliorer la coopération :
miser sur un apprentissage plus coopératif que compétitif à l'école ;
une coopération inconditionnelle au sein des entreprises --
il peut y avoir compétition entre entreprises, mais pas en leur sein.
Il nous faut une harmonie durable. J'adore ce terme.
Et non plus une croissance durable.
Une harmonie durable débute par la réduction des inégalités, maintenant.
À l'avenir, nous ferons plus avec moins,
et on continue à croître qualitativement, et non quantitativement.
Il nous faut une économie bienveillante.
L'Homo Economicus ne peut se permettre de tels écarts entre riches et pauvres,
des problèmes de biens en commun,
de l'atmosphère, des océans.
Il faut une économie bienveillante.
Si vous demandez une économie bienveillante,
ils disent que ce n'est pas son rôle.
Mais si vous qu'ils s'en fichent, ça, ce n'est pas bien.
Il nous faut une engagement local, et une responsabilité mondiale.
On doit étendre l'altruisme aux 1,6 millions d'autres espèces.
Les êtres vivants sont tous co-citoyens de ce monde.
Bref, on a besoin d'oser l'altruisme.
Alors, vive la révolution altruiste.
Viva la revolución de altruismo.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.